I have a
question about the most important issue
of our
day and it's it's about this Zoomer or
maybe Millennial girl whining about
getting fired and I'll hold my question
until I assume you've seen it it went
totally viral but I'll hold my question
until
after she makes her display hi Britney
hi thanks for meeting with me and Rosie
um so she's writing on here she's an
accounting SEC at Cloud flare we
finished our evaluations 23
performance she writes her name here she
go I want to stand up for myself what do
I have to lose we've decided to part
ways with you yeah I'm going to stop you
right there sure um so I started August
25th I've been on a 3mon
ramp and then it was 3 weeks of enjoy
the trauma she WR a week of Christmas
her trauma I guess is what she's are
she's writing these things on the Tik
Tok had the highest activity amongst my
team um since I've started I have had
three contracts out done a really great
job managing my deals up until the very
end that decided not to close last
minute um so I don't think that that
makes a lot of sense for me in my cloud
flare Journey here so
far wow it goes on and on and
on everyone's talking about how she's an
entitled young woman she doesn't get it
you kidding me you buttercup you little
snowflake get with the program that's
one take then the the other take is yeah
Corporate America there's something
really screwy about it and she's
probably right and it's crazy how
clinical her firing was and that is
wrong and she yeah our economy is kind
of messed up and fair enough my take is
not either of those my question
is why does everyone film everything now
why it's kind of ironic I guess because
I'm filming a thing right now I'm saying
my thoughts on a camera to you but one
that's my job and two you know it's
a I'm not filming you know every
traumatic event in my life I don't think
I'm filming any traumatic events in my
life I don't want to I don't want to
expose that I'm not even filming when I
go make pasta I'm not some of you have
asked me to do that but I don't really
do that I'm not the only time I really
film in my house if we're not snowed in
is when I'm making little ukulele videos
why is everyone filming your first
instinct you see someone getting beaten
up on the street you say I got to film
this you you you get fired from your job
you know you're about to get fired you
know it's going to be a traumatic
experience you actually write in the
comment enjoy the trauma and you say
yeah you know what I got to do I got to
stream my firing my humiliation what has
gone wrong with people that they do that
it's it's a it's a total obliteration of
private life to what she's actually
doing here it's a huge mistake she might
be in the right maybe the company just
made a mistake or they're just laying
her off they don't really care they
shouldn't have hired her in the first
place she was doing a fine job maybe
that's the case she's making or maybe
she's a huge problem which would seem to
be the case because of look what she's
doing here can you This Woman's never
going to get a job again should probably
have a better life because of that I
actually don't think that working in the
widget Factory is the the most
wonderful and joyful way of life and I
think that feminists duped a lot of
women into thinking it is and now we
have an economy where women feel that
they have to work and in some cases they
would face real financial problems if
they didn't work and those are all
legitimate problems she's certainly
never going to get a job again though
once people Google her name that she put
out there but why why would you why
would you obliterate your private life
like that well you know actually just
occurs to me it gets back to what we
were talking about earlier with Twilight
and Kristen Stewart saying
all those uh homophobic things even
though she's I guess kind of a lesbian
and
it it it's a total
upending
of the natural
order part of the reason that Dante puts
his teacher Brunetto latini in the
circle of the sodomites it's not I don't
know what the guy did in his private
life it's not even really necessarily
about that it's because bruneta La in
was a very famous poet who sought
immortality in Fame and and
who whose poetry Dante seems to
accuse was disconnected from True ends
it was totally in self-indulgent and
sterile and not fruitful and we do that
today we do that you know why this lady
is filming herself because we don't have
kids anymore I think that's probably why
not just because she's working and that
you know when when women are working it
makes them less likely to have kids but
because we want to be
immortal and the the the devil tricks us
into thinking that the best way to
become immortal is to become a big
celebrity or to I don't know write a
really great book and that's how your
name is going to live forever that
that's not actually how we become the
the natural way to have immortality is
to pass on your
genes it it's to pass on your genes
literally biologically or at the very
least spiritually to be a spiritual
father and a mentor and in fact that can
be more important but it's not it's not
to get your name in
lights I get it's kind of ironic I got a
big light here and I'm filming myself
and I you know I I have a public career
but it's not the most important thing
that I do not even close to it it's not
that all has to be in service of
something else and it it was in our
society for a while and even even when
people you know people would do all
sorts of sins for all of history it's a
fallen world but we at least had the
right sense of that we had the right
sense that the the natural way to have
immortality is to have a family and the
supernatural way given to us by
Supernatural Grace to have immortality
is to follow God and follow the only
begotten Son of God who is Incarnate and
who is crucified and is resurrected on
the third day and redeems us of our sins
and if we have faith in him we might not
perish but have everlasting life that
was that's how you actually get
immortality on the natural and
Supernatural level but we get distracted
all along the way oh I know how I'll get
it I'll write a pretty poem I know how
I'll get it I'll become an Instagram
influencer I was talking to sweet little
Alisa she was telling me because she she
Scrolls a little bit more on that stuff
than I do my my scrolling is Twitter her
scrolling is more like insta and that
kind of stuff she said there are people
who they'll post really humiliating
videos of
themselves you know looking ugly and you
know like eating gross things and in
this case you know experiencing the
trauma of being fired and but they'll
say wow I'm so pleased that I'm an
influencer wow that's something El
you're right you you get that 15 minutes
of fame but it's 15 minutes even if
you're the most famous guy in the world
it's 15 minutes you know and then it's
gone there there is a more enduring way
to have everlasting life the final iow
caucus
polls have Trump with the biggest lead
that he has had yet remember the
DeSantis campaign has staked the whole
campaign on Iowa at this point initially
they were running a Nationwide race when
things were looking quite good and
DeSantis was the clear number two at
least maybe was able to challenge Trump
uh the polls just didn't move it's not
that DeSantis is is a bad candidate it's
not that he's a bad Governor he's a
great Governor I really admire the guy I
think he's great I think the campaign
has made some missteps but even if it
were the greatest campaign ever I just
didn't think it was in the cards as I
observed from the beginning and I hate
to say I told you so uh so because of
that they put all of their resources in
Iowa and it does not appear to have paid
off this latest poll uh has come out
Trump at
48% uh Haley at 20% so Trump's got a 28%
lead 28 point lead over his next nearest
rival Haley at 20 over D Santa at 16 is
pretty shocking I'm somewhat skeptical
of that that Haley is actually going to
outperform D santis in Iowa I guess it
could could happen uh V at 8% which is
considerably lower I still think pretty
good numbers for a guy that no one had
ever heard of a year ago I think he's
done a very good job in this campaign
and he's been able to not have himself
be totally marginalized like a Andrew
Yang type candidate or like a even a Ron
Paul type of candidate he's he's avoided
that he's he's a very sharp guy he's
very disciplined and he might outperform
even this poll ASA Hutchinson still in
it
1% I I didn't realize he was still in
the race but I guess he is and then
there's a guy named Binkley he showed up
on the poll I've never heard of Binkley
but Binkley is in it and who knows maybe
he'll outperform and get a point and a
half who knows there could be a surprise
seems unlikely uh but we'll find out the
votes will be cast right now man that
was a great clip huh I agree make sure
that you ring the Bell subscribe to the
Michael and old Show
podcast we'll see you next time